well one of the president one of
president Trump's most fierce public
defenders is leaving the White House
president's press secretary Sarah
Sanders said yesterday she will step
down after nearly two tumultuous years
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
what does her departure mean for mr.
Trump a good morning Michele here the
president is losing one of his
longest-serving advisors and closest
aides yesterday the president announced
Sanders would be leaving her quote
service to her country but many believe
she did a disservice to her country by
amplifying some of the president's most
controversial claims the president is
losing one of his most loyal soldiers
we've been through a lot together and
she's tough but she's good Sanders has
been a fierce defender of the president
when the president gets hit he's going
to hit back harder which is and help
shape the public face of his presidency
by reshaping the role of press secretary
mostly by stepping aside and letting the
president be his own communicator in
chief the White House briefing
effectively died on her watch the last
one was 95 days ago the liberal media
should be absolutely embarrassed by
their behavior over the last two years
Sanders frequently echoed the
president's talking points there was no
collusion
there was no obstruction there was no
collusion there was no obstruction her
credibility has frequently been called
into question even by robert muller for
defending the president's firing of
James Comey the rank-and-file of the FBI
had lost confidence in their director
Sanders later admitted to Special
Counsel investigators she had no basis
for that claim and it was made in the
heat of the moment I said that it was in
the heat of the moment but the big
takeaway here is that the sentiment is a
hundred percent accurate and there were
many heated moments this is day after
day after day and it's not just the
president that's the only person that I
see a war on as this president and
everybody that works for him behind the
scenes she faced death threats I'm the
first press secretary in the history of
the United States that's required Secret
Service protection still Sanders called
her tenure the opportunity of a lifetime
I've loved every minute even the hard
minutes I've loved it
Sanders is expected to leave her post in
the next few weeks the process is
already underway to find her replacement
and official tell CBS News it is likely
that replacement will come from outside
the press office Michelle Paula Reid at
the White House thank you